hello when welcome to this video this is
the round recap video for round five of
Tata Steel 2016 this is all a little bit
late and apologies for that usually is
on quicker but currently my schedule is
somewhat unpredictable due to my
upcoming move to a new place and after
yeah organize things so the videos are
produced but sometimes a bit later than
I wanted them to be on so what is about
what about round five we had a couple of
very interesting games but also some gap
not as exciting once let's look a bit at
their not so exciting once but at least
that you know what happened yet the game
navara with white against Wesley so and
we had a no-go zone defense Queens
gambit Rogozin which is a good middle of
the road kind of opening its solid but
not like two solids that you can never
win a game and however there are a
couple of very sound choices that white
can play and Navarro goes to something
check which is really solid are taking
on f6 and playing 20 40 s III here I
have played this kind of setup also
number of times but with the early
capture on d5 which is a little bit
different because here black can
actually take on c4 yeah we see a couple
of very logical looking moves and now
I'm yeah black goes for a very simple
solution to this to this position he
just yeah captured on c3 this is not the
only move that you can play I mean black
can play in some more ambitious ways
something like let's say Queen Queen g6
for example this is a playable move you
don't attending maybe go to go here and
yeah keep more pieces on the board
this is however what Wesley is so played
and now here to set up this discovery
threat yeah navara now went to a three
and um the whole situation is a little
bit comparable to some lines of the
lusca defense now we're in the Queens
gambit declined where the darks could
bishop is traded and a pair of night is
traded black in the last car this kind
of structure often manages to equalize
with b6 NC 5 or with e 5 and in this
game with Queenie seven black has those
two ideas yeah for example you five is
very likely to happen in the long run
all that mentioned be 695 c5 thing if
wide rewards the Queen trade for example
black can do this covering also be seven
and then go for c5 and blacks the
equalizing chances are pretty pretty
okay the bishop can drop back to eight
just to be out of the way and later
maybe come to a for c6 something like
that it's pretty okay and over i decided
to trade and yeah now we very early only
get some kind of endgame where white has
a little bit more space but it's not
really very likely that this is going to
be anything else than a draw note that
the clock times are not in any way right
yeah because this is some out of the
game library because the current round
round six is already on and therefore
the clock times get lost in the files
yeah they trade it a little bit more and
yeah why it has a little symbolic
advantage to two more space but
this is a very precise move here by so
with c5 getting d again see portray that
even always get his porn back down just
had to be a little bit precise and
calculation no the serpent white can
also check off on b7 but simply nothing
nothing happens here yes hope they
continue a little bit chance and game
check check actually play to her
backings yes so not very exciting what
can you do it's a it's a solid to solid
opening and both sides had one or two
opportunities to make a little bit more
interesting but they didn't go for it
next game to check is why ye with white
onigiri yeah it's an Oberlin it's the
night off that's good news but
unfortunately after Bishop e3 94 Bishop
c190 of 6 they made a draw no they
didn't but this is a one issue here
white if he goes for the English attack
with Bishop e3 he has to be ready
nowadays in most cases 494 just to move
on the top level and um it seems that
white has issues with them proving
something if we check this he has to has
issues proving something here when black
goes for this this kind of thing and
currently has good chances them so what
happens quite often is they repeat once
or twice and then white as he wants to
continue the game and not make a drawn
move seven or eight yeah play something
else and in this case why he comes up
with g3 so that line is very very sound
very solid but also not very exciting I
have to admit it's one of those chain
safe choices what white often goes for
is some slope is regrouping to try to
make use of the d5 square which is
arguably weakened however this takes
along
and in the meantime give me here hat is
a nice regroup anger with the bishop
over to a five the bishop only seven is
actually not that bad but if you can get
it out of the chain there is also no
harm in doing so God Bishop T 292 very
cautious movie our trade down and that
also got traded and here and the
position is roughly equal any possible
pressure on the g6 pawn is nullified by
blacks counter play for example if we
look at something like this why it takes
and place like rooty one yeah then I'd
be 64 94 is good and b3 route g8 and in
this kind of position I'd rather be
black because yeah the bishop on g2 is
not a very good piece black has some
player answer C porn which is actually
more realistic and more relevant than
the d6 pawn even though I'm not claiming
black is badder I'm just saying that
it's not even easier for y to play or
anything like that yeah in the game why
he went for before which is a move that
surprised me really quite a bit because
I didn't see the upside of weakening
your Yossi file and in the game there
also was no I mean there was no ops
upside really it just slightly strange
move and but it doesn't seem to be yeah
hurting white so much it's just not
quite clear why he had weakened the
square and yeah kind of devalued his
pawns here but at the end White has
counter player against his six and the
way it went we had some trade here d 6
against you for and yeah Black has a
symbolic advantage there in some in some
way but White's pieces are still active
enough so ultimately we got those good
more trades in
they they traded this down to rook
endgame and agreed to draw yeah it
wasn't very exciting but a very correct
game ultimately um yeah why chooses
something very solid yet against the
night off it's difficult to do much even
though it's nowadays a bit tough free
free go all the way back just to make it
quick remark them it's nowadays quite
tough to get something really
interesting against the night off at
least on the very top level because they
have yeah the sharp lines this should be
three as i said 'no g-force believed to
be quite good there after Bishop g5
you've got those super sharp looking
lines which are ya analyzed to death and
what is there left in terms of sharp
plane yeah they try h3 nowadays a lot
which can get sharp but not so much
after you five so there are not many
yeah pure hacking options here for white
much of it is already somewhat yeah
somewhat analyzed to death that same
with the help of modern engines okay um
next game to check is Tomashevsky alien
off and yeah I can actually tell you a
little bit about the opening because
they played in line this line that I've
got in my book and chad is some fairly
good line I think for black this kind of
this kind of bogo Catalan hybrid yeah i
was a little bit quickly i mean okay I'm
I know the position because I wrote the
book but said I should talk about it a
little bit yeah it's the pure Catalan
move order g3 and now that Bishop b4
check is quite a decent alternative to
the Catalan with d5 or the Benoni with
with c5 and after the check I mean why
does somewhat limited with g3 so
we know that why it's not going to play
with III and so on and especially the
option 92 is now entirely different to
the position with the night being on f3
because here after c5 and then now a 3
the taste the big difference is that if
there would be a knight on f3 here then
white could actually take with the
bishop and now he cannot he has to take
with the Queen this makes g3 Bishop
before check 92 c5 a little bit better
then the same position with the knight
on f3 and here black I think has good
equalizing chances even though he has
given up the bishop and it's a little
bit weak on the dark squares the point
is that why does making many moves here
with them with the Queen and then spend
the tempo on a three so Lex development
is very good night at three trying to
still take with the Knight b6 that is
arguing that here white has to place a
movie does not want to play a group g1
oh I have three so why does playing this
Bishop p.m. and now the the main
continuation is to take with the Queen
or deform um after which for example
black can go here here and castle or
luke c8 actually sorry rook c8 and now
Black gets counter play with nitro a
five quick counter play against upon
black it's just very well developed he
has some some compensation for the loss
of the bishop am in terms of his quick
mobilization however castles was played
by Tomashevsky and here I enough goes
from interesting idea that in fact funny
enough to my chefs key himself had
played in a game and the capture on a
three this is something that I also
mentioned in my book it's not my main
line but it's a line that I mentioned as
a good alternative um yeah Tomashevsky
took with the bishop now in that game
that he had played with black Sega
Volkov took with the pawn which I
actually think it's quite interesting
the idea is that why we'll go f1 then be
four there should be two and get the
pawn back black it's not able to keep
the point anyway but I think this kind
of pawn structure with f4 maybe is a
little bit more interesting as white
sometimes has f5 for example with two F
points you have more options there it's
an interesting choice after this 96 the
problem is a little bit that it's
difficult for white to make any headway
here he squeezed a pawn down and if you
play it like too much chef ski did you
have nothing but I don't see what
exactly he should do he played b 3
cancels Bishop b2 a group c 8 and now
took the porn back and it's difficult to
improve on that to be perfectly honest
because what exactly is why it's idea
you know you can try like b4 b5 but then
you weaken your seaport so much that
it's really not worth it so this is why
I mentioned the move Bishop takes their
three because it feels very solid it
wasn't my main move because I felt that
black has something slightly more
interesting to play than this position
but here after this this this structure
is well known to be totally fine for
black one reason is that this Bishop is
yeah on paper let's say here the better
piece then the night as it is in most
cases but the bishop he isn't attacking
anything it's sitting on a somewhat
empty diagonal and black just has to be
somewhat precise with his sit and wait
but it's just that it's sit and wait
like this 6 now you can take on the six
but this doesn't lead to anything rather
white and sometimes has to be careful
that this point is not a weakness and
black has no problems in keeping the d6
pawn and at the same time having counter
play against see form it's especially
difficult iam to imagine any sort of
porn
on break through and this is the only
way for y to make any headway you would
need the points to advance somehow but
if you do your week in your king so much
what does that lead to two lots of
shuffling this is the game it's just
just like sitting down it looks very
uninspiring but it's a case of both
sides being so sound and solid that if
you try to do something yeah forwards
yet something active then you weaken
yourself it's a typical kind of
situation that sometimes happens when
games are looking totally boring and in
fact they are but it just sometimes
about early choices and like okay let's
go for that solid structure but it
sometimes so much so much yeah it's a
situation where both sides actually
should not do anything because they
would weaken their position more than
they would approve it so a draw in this
game as well let's have a look at the
game Caruana who you find now two
players that can be very satisfied with
the event I think at least in general
kawana certainly would have loved to win
the game against tarnish geary that he
yeah he had a win basically on the on
the board but but he needed to be just
one more move one more move of precision
in the rook endgame to get to win until
your phone at a very nice win over
navara and sitting there on +1 a very
good very good result okay so heavily
let's have a look at this game or let's
say mostly add one or two critical
situation situations we found played the
the petrol of defense not something that
I usually yet associate with her playing
that opening she's normally playing a
sharper Sicilians but being a little bit
more solid
not such a bad choice especially against
a very ambitious and sharp theoretical
players Carolina so the Petrov and
karana goes for 93 nowadays maybe the
main line on them on the top level
almost on any level it's also what i
usually recommend against the Petrov the
Petrov is a somewhat underrated opening
it's really very very yeah tough to
crack and if you play one of the
traditional main lines like 3d four or
five deform set of 93 you also have
trouble to fight for some real advantage
but it is just much more effort to learn
those those lines and this is a this
this line is it somewhat simple choice
that still offers chances to try for
doing something ok so and this is the
main line nowadays black is delaying
castling and in most cases will Castle
long canceling short quite often proved
to be risky because white is often
initiating some kind of porn storm and
there's a bit quicker than blackest so
we had aged six year preventing 95 an
interesting idea that is very often
happening in this lines that Nigerian
the bishop pair but she just stops this
idea yeah III back kawana the 82 pawn is
sometimes really hanging yeah so it's
not completely mysterious there you
might think that black can never take
because of you three but sometimes there
are ideas with a5 a4 and so on so this
has some yeah this has some merit yeah
she now play drooped g8 it's a very
interesting idea of trying to possibly
play g5 yeah in some cases as possible
and we see that in the game very
interesting way to play the position and
she's delaying still canceling I mean
it's clear now that black book has long
after root yet but still she didn't play
it yet okay 94 that is a also common
idea to to get either the pawns and
doubled or to activate yeah this was
also a viable move trying to play t5
however after black goes d5 it's it
doesn't feel like black has much to fear
to be honest it's a completely
symmetrical structure so yeah this is
maybe a little bit more dynamic she went
for c5 and d5 and now cancelled long I
think black should be okay yeah i mean
computers see absolutely nothing and
give equality and i really don't i
cannot add much to that to that
assessment if you like black has no
problems here and in fact the way it
continued Kuryakin didn't sorry I'm
karana didn't get anywhere I was
thinking of kayaking but because he's
one of the big specialists of that live
in white yeah they they got into that
end game with him and corona decided to
take which I found slightly surprising
to go for that structure because I would
think that if anybody can do something
in this position it would be black
because of the three against two am I
mean those pawns are not very mobile at
the moment I cannot yeah move forward
quickly and promote to a queen but yeah
that that double point looks fairly
useless here on them on the queenside so
nothing much happened up to a certain
point we got we got here no black was
moving us in her bones forward that's
one particular moment and this is here
is this him no lancia move 35 I'm sorry
yeah yeah in this position now white
should play the move f4 check something
similar happens in the game yeah f4
check check like cheeks Bishop cheeks
and this position is roughly equal yeah
we see it almost the same position in
the game at least we see the same
structure now here black might go for
gap b6 let's say and trade off the a
porn it's very equal ish this is nice
for black it looks like um chances for a
passer but still difficult to break down
why this is probably not in big danger
of losing um cara wanna play this move
however setting up potential pin there
so f1 is a big blunder but who you find
an excellent chance now she could play
the move Bishop to f7 not this one
Bishop to f7 look Shane is what she
played but this is much stronger the
problem is that white now must take on
g5 there is no alternative any other
move is made check checkmate yeah very
embarrassing checkmate so what has to
take and now black plays King to f6 and
this is a big issue now the rook is
strapped white has to play king of four
only move and now f5 hangs but just
cover it and this is a very funny
situation the rook has look moves and
black has this idea and Luke coming on
the second rank he is very effective as
f2 is hanging with a pretty big check
plus c2 hanging + b2 hanging here white
is in absolute grave danger of losing um
the relatively best is probably g-form
trying to yeah break up this situation
you that the root can
can move ultimately but after work T to
for example Teague's Bishop f7 um yeah
white is struggling yeah why this really
struggling something like here check
like starts to take pawns I don't not
sure I think white will probably lose
this game it's very very likely that
that black will win here no it'sit's
this moves away somewhere tix I don't
know I mean you can always fight but
this is very likely very likely going to
be a loss for what so that was a big
opportunity for who you find it was also
completely forced this is important
white cannot do anything else he has to
do that Bishop chief Luke 25 and so on
so a big opportunity here for the former
I probably future women world champion
yeah Luke g8 me leg is ok now still but
now White has the chance to play a form
and we get to the mansion structure in
fact um the way it went just the odds
improvement maybe for black yeah because
at the end of this I'm going to fast
forward a little bit here at the end of
this she decided to just drop the elf
porn and go for a drone ruka head game
but check and still yeah this drawing
look and game still it feels like um
black um shouldn't actually be in this
situation because at the start of it it
was just a very comfortable draw with
black rather being better but on the
other hand this is a complete draw and
therefore well yeah it's it's it's not
not a big deal because you can only lose
here if you are very um yeah very
negligent yeah you just have to be a
little bit careful and don't do anything
stupid just check oh it's amazing how
bad the comp assessments of those
positions it's just completely data and
stock pushes on 1.4 like a total win for
white which is complete Joe
yeah anyway the only thing that I said
that black needs to do is show yeah be a
little bit alert for example like here's
what we are going to get now that you
calculate precisely this is a draw now
here White has no win he can try this a
six business but it's not yeah and Chazz
you are not forced to take pawns so
please not this which leads to a quick
win but just King b8 after which is a
drew after which it is a draw yeah like
a sand King 8 and it's an automatic
stalemate now or white cannot avoid the
stalemate yeah so at the end a draw and
even though who you find is probably not
delighted that she missed that chance to
play Bishop f7 and maybe win the game
even I think it was still a very a very
good performance seeing that if her
opening results are cave that she can
absolutely play with those guys I mean
it's not it's not like she's getting out
played every game or something like that
it's quite the opposite it's not it's
not the case that in middle games that
are equal ish that she tends to drift
into bad positions just and just not the
case so very good performance I think
and yeah even somewhat undervalued in
terms of points she could have maybe won
that game okay so um what's next kind of
an organized here with my notes what's
next let's do ding Liren kayaking so
here we go queen's india near we are not
very popular nowadays on the top level
which is not due to the Queen's Indian
being a bad opening but I think one
reason is why it is not seen so often is
that why it has so many different
systems against
and it's probably not so easy to keep
track of all of those systems it's it's
a little bit more straightforward to
prepare in the Queens gambit for example
with black waiters often reduce to one
or two critical lines in the Queen's
Indian white can play a 3g 393 and this
ain't within with many little twists and
turns maybe this is the reason why it's
not played so often k aquino ever is a
very regular Queens Indian player and
probably the world's leading expert so
interesting to see what ding is coming
up with they play this Bishop 86 line
and now black shirts for c6 and t5 yeah
the most interesting continuation now bc
4 which is played bad thing d5 yeah and
here white has a choice of course it can
also play the capture on d 5v5 or this
move still not probably not the main
line but an interesting choice it shows
that it's not mandatory to if you catch
of the bishop even though you have
started with 4g 3 the typical case of
modern chest I think this approach would
have raised some eyebrows and that
eyebrows in the 1950s or 60s for example
yeah ok anyway this happened and very
normal looking position here in in
earlier games white played something
pretty conventional even to part of was
known to be very enterprising player
play tonight xf6 hands position after
this and Castle short and yeah this
position type is well known from many
openings some lines of the semis la for
example or the Catalan or even some fo
openings like caracarno French defense
yeah blackboard plays c5
some point but why it has a little bit
more space so maybe a very very slight
advantage thanks very solid though yeah
so I think ding wanted something sharper
and therefore he castle no um not sure
about the objective merits of the move
but it at least them yeah sets problems
or leads to something that is a general
well explored one point of the gap of
long castles IAM is that the rook is
very quickly on the D file therefore
making c5 based approach is a little bit
more difficult yeah black plays c5 for
example you have to reckon with things
like d5 as an interesting direct option
yeah what kayaking did I think is
interesting he took on you for what so
very logical move Knight f6 Bishop back
and now we went a five yeah definitely
definitely a playable trying to play a
four was also possible to start with B 5
move that he plays some plays later the
point is that if white tries to be
greedy like takes then black has some
the strong move room c 8 the thing is
that white is is not really that keen on
having this extra pawn the rook is on a
great Oh pop open file the bishop is
strong at d5 is an excellent blockading
square so this is not in whites interest
after be five wide will probably play c5
after which we get something quite
comparable to the game even though it's
not clear that you need to play a valve
before has happened in the game we'll
see what happened a5 rookie 1 p-5 c5 so
it's quite kind of similar structure um
before now was played and g-form yeah of
course what needs to do something here
play dynamically
yeah blacks again later castle king it's
not just about it may be playing for
checkmate of course what would love to
deliver mate but it's also about gang
space near the whole problem here for
black is that he is suffering from
slight disadvantage in space here yeah
now was an interesting choice black had
two options can go to d5 or to h5 and he
decided to go to age 5 which costs the
porn thing is what happens if he goes to
d5 here also I think white retains
pretty decent player he's got this idea
just March the age porn up so one in one
line White has a very strong attack and
in the other line in the game as I'm
seaman he was a porn down and I'm
absolutely not sure if black has enough
there for the pawn I mean White's King
looks a little bit shaky on the
queenside but the way it turned out like
like this um there was no real attack
and after the Queen trade here check
here why just has the better end game
and a very comfortable endgame because
night is offside take some time to
regroup and what's more those pawns can
be a very yeah a very annoying weakness
in the long run as they can be easily
attacked by White's Bishop and whites
king is quicker near the action if
things get traded down so this is not a
very good any game at all I mean black
has to suffer here played here and now
we get this transformation yeah here
what is a lot better really a lot
there's also the idea to bring the night
here to attack a 5 and what now follows
is an excellent technical display
bye-bye ding Liren yeah black never gets
anywhere close to save himself you know
why does attacking the weakness
activates the side nope if you trade him
it's it's immediately over that pawn is
very very weak and whites play is also
somewhat somewhat simple and keep the
bishop take this and black has no play
rook t5 is a little bit Tampa even
though this also leads to a good end
game because the bishop here is a lot
stronger than the night because the
bishop can I take those pawns and the
black knight doesn't have anything to
counter-attack this is also why why does
happily trading rooks yeah and that's it
for the airport why the shop owner
what's the last to win he has a very
clear plan however we routes that Bishop
check until the text before porn check
it now brings the king of
now the night needed to go down in order
to stop the King from entering I've chat
something like this white is happily
just invading the end after this now
White has a clear continuation just
activate the bishop a little more and
now went to e3 and now the winning plan
is f4 f5 and over yeah black can just
shuffle around here like this and now f5
or you can also know h4 first let's
deceive more precise this and white will
promote the pawn or it will cost the
cost the night so a very nice gambia
biding who's no 1 plus 2 with a very
good result in the event it's actually
not so easy to pinpoint what kayaking
did wrong oh yeah I'm pretty sure that
long castles shouldn't lead to some
substantial advantage for what yeah I
think black should be somewhat ok
because it does not have doesn't seem to
have made any any mistakes ahead say it
so it's very difficult to imagine that
he should be in trouble but it's not
easy to give them advice I mean it's
pretty clear that this position here got
tricky maybe it's a matter of timing and
black should not castle that earlier
maybe start with this and try to put
something on c3 or play for a 4 maybe
this is better yeah but it'sit's field
form for analysis that I couldn't do at
this particular yeah point point in time
it's definitely a very sharp position
that would have led to learn to
interesting interesting player as well
however not easy for black very
interesting idea here with the long
castles ok so let's have a look at the
game Omidyar of arrows next
nims Oh nims O'Quinn's Indian hybrid
peek at my notes and mojo is playing a
very very modest set up here with Bishop
t2 and rook see one yeah it's a leather
set very modest but not not bad of
course yeah it's just not the kind of
line that will refute this opening which
is not possible anyway so it's all
pretty normally a pretty normal
development Queen to e7 83 it's quite
funny I always if I'm only preparing for
the videos I'm always asking my my
database to to prepare or two to give me
some info on possible novelties if there
was a novelty played or when what was
the what was there a new idea
theoretically speaking and it was quite
funny to see that in this position there
was a game from 1986 between xuereb as
my parish really and Silvio done I love
and I kind of couldn't help to think of
this as the end of the final of the
Russian general championships or
something like that because those people
yeah they're probably am well anyway
let's not discuss that and we have a 3m
enter very typical Queens Indian names
of type of structure interesting moment
TM is often light a 4d 694 and
concentrate check the chick here and a 3
and d 5 yeah it's an interesting
interesting structure that a 5 b 6 with
the nigerian a form and I think what um
Mammadyarov is now playing the next
couple of moves they don't quite add up
he plays 9 p-3
Adams went back and queen deform and I
don't think that this is particularly
great to be honest because after be five
which is what Adams played I think black
gets pretty good play went here between
eight seven six a four very interesting
play black gets active on the on the
queenside and galleon 8 a-1 was played
this move looks strange and it is also
very much disliked by my computers and
they want to play something like Queen
edge form which is a very yeah unhuman
move to play yeah the point is amazingly
that after something like rook e8 now
you can ask yourself what is the idea if
the night moves isn't that Bishop that
Bishop just taking on see fire that
completely wacky computer idea is to
play rugby 48 eggs and rook a form yeah
and the engine is stock which in that
case is assessing this position as equal
yeah completely inhuman way the troop to
approach a game yeah what Mammadyarov is
doing it you just move the night away
but now black is definitely in good
shape Queen to be 62 just take b5 and
this is what happened Queen took here
and now mum jar of when to c5 and here
is the first mysterious moment in the
game um I simply couldn't figure out why
am Adam now is playing what he is
playing it's not that his position after
his movies bad he played 96 and black
retained very decent compensation for
the porn however I couldn't figure out
what what the problem was was just
taking material back something like
check this tanks was check Queen f2 and
now just go back I think black ass in
a good shape here and has pressure
against this and the pawns and the night
on the night in the corner I mean black
is just fine without being a pawn down
and I don't know I mean this is maybe
just me but if I have the choice between
being fine and a pawn down and being
fine with equal material I just take the
letter so I couldn't quite understand
why not just take the pawn with check
there was also the capture on c5 which
maybe was a little bit too simple or so
to play but here also black is fine
after room takes you can again snatch
this pawn yes now Queen f2 is not
impossible so this probably add queen
bee too and also here I think black is
just in good shape and this is a
weakness and you are not a porn down
yeah knight c6 was played and now 95
attending night c4 I mean he probably
wanted more but just being fined with
eco material is good black also could
have taken be too there was no
particular reason not to do that ok
Knight e5 was played 93 and after this
this and this black still has
compensation we shouldn't forget that
this is pretty awful and white pawns are
also yeah more of a weakness then a
strength rooks III yeah now we see how
black still has pressure but position is
uncorrelated now here black also there
were there were a couple of alternatives
here wrong around here but the main
issue is what black did a couple of
moves later he's drifting a little bit
in this position after white was able to
get the night to before that wasn't
necessary in the first place but black
is still okay he just made a mistake
somewhat later
go ahead a little bit check ya here if
black now takes on e to managers takes
it green tea eggs and now Bishop deform
black still has quite decent
compensation for his pawn it's it's not
super clear cut but if you analyze a
little bit um the compensation becomes
more and more apparent engine just gives
000 basically telling that black is fine
which is not so obvious admittedly but
it's clearly better than what happened
Adams played this and now another porn
got lost on d5 and here you absolutely
don't have the compensation now after
luke t aidid's it's over yeah I black
can take on g2 but probably it was
somewhat disconcerted by now being
clearly aware that his position was good
at one point root G to where the point
is of course that check me this is made
so we will get some kind of endgame here
where black is is a porn down but can
continue to fight for example rucksacks
Queen takes Queen tha king of eight
something like Queenie for maybe um
black will get one point back and
probably will lose but yeah you can
fight in the game after p8 this was just
two parts without any any kind of any
kind of compensation so as slightly in
my book weird loss because yeah Adams
was in good shape for for most of the
game and it was more of a question if
mohmmad Yara of can can hold are somehow
coordinate is slightly weird position
and animus just refused to get the porn
bag and there were a couple of
surprising decisions or hard too hard
too
understand decisions okay that leaves
one game then really Carlton let's shoot
for that one yup here it is yeah this is
a little bit like a now-or-never game
yeah if Carson wants to win that
tournament he should start to win games
and if you play against the relatively
lowest rated participant at least go for
a fight and don't really try it he
really tried cars and played the gruene
felt not one of his typical mainstay
openings but something that he has in
his repertoire I'm leading to sharper
played arguably then what he is playing
normally like a Queens gambit declined
or names or whatever and it really goes
for a solid line and interestingly the
same line that I also play and carlton
goes for Bishop to e6 this is the the
modern main line off of this of this
particular variation the move looks a
little bit strange but black is
attacking the c-4 porn and it's all
about concrete plane you know why it has
to do something about it if why play
screen to be three here for example then
black can go see five which is very
sharp but believed to be good for black
or equal ish and white can play C 5
which is my move after which the
situation quite often it's more looking
like a sloth defense and a green felt
when black is often playing something
like c6 and later tries to go for you
five I think that black is actually
quite okay here but I always felt that
this is more testing than the capture
button not sure this was also played in
earlier game in the in the challenger
school by dre f and he won a game with
it so maybe something for me to look at
antiques Teague's bishop Teague's via
Queen txt five is also also like is
giving up on him
but now immediately regained it on hmm
it looks a little bit strange that
Bishop on a two but white has no
particular opportunity to capture it
something like be three for example is
counted by 25 and it's now it's a
problem yeah something like this is not
leading anywhere I think when we least
move was perfectly fine 92 however as I
learned while i'm looking through the
round reports he took vote took a very
long time for the move which looks
little bit which is a bit strange
because it's not a very um yeah a
difficult move to play ultimately of
course you check be three but i think he
spent more than 30 minutes on it and
this seems excessive because once you
have discarded b3 i think getting the
nitrous III looks like the most natural
weather so let's see what happens here
yeah yeah white of course can play um
let's say standard-looking moves now you
want to develop your bishop so hmm what
about this should be to Bishop d3 yeah
g2 is hanging that Bishop eaiser has a
nice spot so a suggestion is to play f3
just blunt that Bishop for a moment and
then develop it there should be two and
castles it looks very very ok actually
for y now something like this yeah Black
is ok as well and don't get me wrong but
there were solid ways to play when video
ever is never shying away from conflict
and he goes h4 I don't think this is bad
just um well it's playing with fire a
little bit if you have spent so much
time and you are down on the clock
against the world champion so it's not a
bad mmm Group D 8 and now we went queen
bee three first h5 also was possible
yeah I think the next move by cards
is probably a little bit too ambitious
you played queen to f5 trying to to use
the Queen actively which is a very
understandable idea that you want to
play the Queen them out and then only
then play a possible e 6 to stop any D
45s however it seems to have some
concrete issues after age 56 cake sticks
then really played Queen 31 one
additional idea of Queen f5 also was to
look at look at the d3 square so Bishop
d3 is not so easily possible Queen d1
when various move from is preparing the
development with Bishop d3 however it
seems that with the farm one direct move
on night to be five he could have could
have gotten an interesting and probably
quite good position 97 is them the
simple threat and yeah I mean the engine
likes by the lot iam I'm just not sure
how how big white some initiative is
here but he definitely seems to be very
okay something like this is given by the
engine for example and it looks looks
quite decent for what yeah even though
here this is probably requiring some
kind of weird-looking move but so that's
97's 96 around the corner and the Queen
doesn't have many squares so this is a
line given by a stock fish for example
and this is a very nice position four ID
so 95 was maybe a way to question cards
and set up here Queen d1 was played and
now 97 Queen comes over here and now
King f1 and to keep g2 coverage yeah
white also could have castled I mean
this isn't a bad move yeah but it's
difficult to castle once you have yeah
played age for it looks a little bit
very unnatural to
it then Castle yeah anyway King f1 and
it's okay it's not a bad at all why do I
think it's perfectly okay here 2294
training this and now m3 by then really
trying to push the night back yeah now
we come to the critical situation that
um it's them defining moment father for
the whole game here cousin um of course
can just go back to f6 and probably has
an equal position about equal yeah the
age file is not a big deal black can go
look at eight but after you for it's
quite difficult to do anything with
black anything sensible funny funny line
is given by the computers here with
night h5 g5 check check and all of a
sudden why it has an attack but can't
see five check 26 is ok for black again
check yeah what did cards do him he
played Queen to g5 just sacrificing the
night well that's not the usual hood
style of play for the world champion but
he probably felt like okay I have to
risk a little something here I mean and
when really was down to a couple of
minutes so this is not a correct p
sacrifice we have to be perfectly honest
their white is better after he is taking
the piece and he did of course he took
the night there was no choice and also
it's also I think quite clear yeah if
you are the white player here that
probably what black is just doing is
gambling and it I think this is also
perfectly clear to cards and velveeta
that this was a gambling kind of
sacrifice a little bit because it's hard
to believe that black should have
objectively enough for the piece however
the practical problems are quite
substantial
especially considering that men really
didn't have much time on the clock you
played king to you one that is a very
good movie actually played that phase of
the game very well King you want and I
think here um Queenie five gardens move
which looks quite quite normal quite
logical might be actually not so great
um engines suggest something else which
might be a little bit better but it's
it's it's tough to say then the whole
position is very difficult to play
something like this is what what the
engines give again black has two parts
for their father piece wise King is
insecure White's pawn structure is bad
in a practical game very often you will
get like a third porn and al que ya or
get to the king here I think white well
shouldn't lose but this is a very very
decent practical fighting opportunity
for black after cartons move Queen to e5
it seems that what went vidya did was
very strong he played night to you too
attacking the rook now for real it took
here very logical and now if form that
is very very strong very strongly played
and now after after a form and it's a
very critical moment now for cars
because here it seems that he had to
play the move g5 but after that blacks
position isn't great there we have to be
honest there what he did is what looks
like the the move to play the logical
follow-up to take this however should
lose yeah so when really now had the
opportunity to win against the world
champion he could have done dancer with
Queen age six he did that but now the
next move is the thing here he played
rook to c3 which yeah seems to be yeah
just equal ultimately I mean Black now
has three Pawn says it's not like black
um this black has a huge material
deficit but what you could have done is
Queen age four and it seems that this
move ultimately wins yeah we can have a
look at some lights if black goes back
here it's very easy Chad check and rook
f1 Chan or if black steps back just
create h 8 f even check winning a full
rook so Chad doesn't work Queen to g5 is
answered by 75 check well and here check
checkmate legs even getting checkmated
if he goes here check check we have this
again so yeah please black supposed to
play yeah the relatively best-looking
move is g5 but now after Queen 83
amazingly the white rook as the black
rook on sorry on g2 is trapped it's
completely trapped so what black and he
had to do is you have needed to take and
yeah Chad and black can try to play on
here yeah with the look down for three
pawns and whites King still somewhat
shaky even though objectively speaking
here wife must be winning so it is a
dodge bullets here for cars and after
Roxy three he is ok again yeah so he
took a huge gamble there with that piece
Jack P sacrifice but it paid off yeah as
when really here mrs. chance and the
game continues it still has to make a
couple of moves with very little time in
yeah in this still very complicated
position so whoopty aid or all those
moves are actually totally fine
check and white is still equal yeah it's
not in trouble but I mean objectively
speaking in trouble and this is all the
difference between y and looking at a
computer evaluation of 000 and playing
the position over the board with no type
is really a tremendous the practical
problems here absolutely absolutely am
great iam 44 white ya hear what you
should have done is not to d4 this is
given by by the computers yeah black of
course cannot take check due to the
capture and white might be able to just
take the bishop which would help
enormously as the bishop is so strong
yeah what the computers give us
something like this screen DX gx5 check
and some sequence like that will
probably lead to a perpetual because
white can also not do much this is
attacked and the rooks here are very
active what you played however is not f4
and you can almost guess how it ends
yeah after night air for black is much
better yeah Queen to h4 now is a very
annoying pin and by now it's probably
almost impossible to save the relatively
best continuation was not G to check and
check this is a very nice point check
check and black chasm has an excellent
position even though it's not clear that
you that you that you definitely will
win it yeah something like this takes
check check check check
check that's a bit long that line
somewhere here yeah I mean black should
should win this even though you can
still continue to fight a little bit
after Bishop eat or ever it's
immediately also there's a check we
should have won only move and now now
black wins directly with a five but
Carson couldn't many also he had more
time than when Vinny did but not like an
ages he said he couldn't find something
super clear so he played the move King
2g8 which is just keeping the whole
thing as it is and let's wide me yeah
and ask right for a move and Carlton
said he couldn't find a good move for
white so he just went for that and
sometimes this is a good approach that
the other guy find him moving with with
with tan trouble and in fact the move 92
what when we need it loses instantly but
it would have been very difficult anyway
chan this is chan what happened yeah let
him when really resides so the first win
for Carlton involve shaky win yeah
because when really had the opportunity
to to take to play Queen edge for check
with with the winner but still I feel
like it's good that Carlton is taking
those risks occasionally not just
relying on his technical kind of
abilities yeah if you are a much better
player and you have more time on the
clock test you should take the odd
chance and see what to see what happens
quite often in practical games as we've
seen in countless countless games by
those dynamic legends like Thailand
Kasparov very often people can go wrong
so some risk here and there certainly
will pay off if you want to win a
tournament you have to take some risks
okay so an interesting round here that
round five I'll be back with round six
coverage probably a lot earlier in this
time thanks for watching guys